Operation of a transistor.
In the image above we see an electronic circuit where the lamp is off because
the transistor does not let the current pass to the other side and what will
be necessary for this transistor to maintain this current?
In order to activate it,
it will be necessary to inject a small chain into its base,
this chain cannot be too small or too big.
Now notice,
if we throw a small signal from a magnetic plate,
the little current will flow inside the transistor,
causing the current in the collector to flow to the emitter,
thus making the system work,
and if you want to cross the circuit just remove the base current.
In this other example we will play a minimum voltage and see that
the transistor only released when it reached six volts.
A simpler example we can show is in this hydraulic system,
let's say that the water is making its way and it is interrupted by
this pin and suddenly we throw another base pin,
when this bass pin receives a small force,
it will release the passage of water and when this little force is
interrupted the water will be blocked.
That's how the transistor works.